DAN GALPIN: In the
early days of Android,
we made the first SDK available
as a preview to developers.
The vibrant developer
ecosystem and open platform
have been important keys
to our success, which
is why I'm excited that we're
once again giving developers
a very early preview of some of
what's in store in the upcoming
version of Android--
Android P. Your early feedback
is crucial to our efforts
to push the boundaries
of mobile development.
In Android P,
JobScheduler has been
improved to let it better
handle network-related jobs.
Jobs can now declare
their estimated data size,
signal prefetching and specify
detailed network requirements.
For example, when a network
is reported by the carrier
as being congested, JobScheduler
might defer large network
requests while it can take
advantage of surplus meter
capacity to run a prefetch
job that returns content that
will substantially
improve the app's user
experience, such as
prefetching top headlines.
Android P brings performance
and efficiency improvements
to ART, Android's runtime.
We've expanded ART's use
of execution profiles
to optimize apps and reduce
the in-memory footprint
of compiled app code.
ART now uses profile information
for on-device rewriting
of DEX files with
reductions of up to 11%
across a range of popular apps.
These correlate closely with
reductions in system DEX memory
usage and faster startup times.
Kotlin is seeing massive growth
in the developer community.
We have heard so much
Kotlin love from developers,
and we are deepening
our Kotlin investments.
In P, you'll see the first
results of our platform work
with new optimizations in ART.
Apps written with Kotlin
will run faster on P
than on previous
versions of Android.
We're continuing to work
with JetBrains to optimize
the Kotlin compiler.
And we are also improving
our brand new D8 dexer
to make sure generated
code from Kotlin
can run as fast as possible.
Also, make sure to check out
our ongoing preview of Android
KTX, which is a set
of extensions designed
to make Android Kotlin
development even more
concise and pleasant.
Android introduces an
easier way to decode images
to either Bitmaps or Drawables
with ImageDecoder, which
replaces BitmapFactory.
ImageDecoder lets you
create a Bitmap or Drawable
from a ByteBuffer, file, or URI.
It offers several advantages
over BitmapFactory including
support for exact scaling,
single-step decoding
to hardware memory, support
for post-processing and decode,
and decoding of animated images.
ImageDecoder allows you
to supply a callback that
is called after the header
is decoded where you
can alter the output
rather than having
to decode the header twice.
Decode Drawable allows you
to create Drawables directly.
If the encoded image is
an animated GIF or WebP,
the Drawable will be an instance
of the new animated image
Drawable.
To help deliver the highest
quality viewing experience,
Android P adds built-in
support for HDR VP9 Profile
2 enabling the delivery
of HDR-enabled movies.
We also added support for
substantially improved image
compression with HEVC
compressed HEIF images,
which means smaller downloads
and less on-device storage.
And we're in the process of
enhancing and refactoring
the media APIs, so stay tuned.
You can access
streams simultaneously
from devices that
have logical cameras
consisting of multiple
physical devices,
such as dual front
or dual rear cameras,
enabling new app possibilities.
Other improvements in camera
include new session parameters
to reduce delays
during initial capture
and surface sharing, reducing
the need for camera clients
to stop and start
camera streaming.
We've also added APIs for
display-based flash support
and access to OIS
timestamps to allow
apps to perform
image stabilization
or use this data
for special effects.
Android P adds an API for the
IEEE 802.11 MC Wi-Fi protocol,
also known as Wi-Fi
Round Trip Time RTT,
to let you take advantage
of indoor positioning
in your apps.
Android P devices
with hardware support
can use RTT to
measure the distance
to a nearby Wi-Fi access point
that supports the protocol.
The device doesn't need to
connect to the AP to use RTT.
And to maintain
privacy, only the phone
is able to determine
the distance.
By measuring distances to
three or more access points,
apps can calculate
their position
with an accuracy
of 1 to 2 meters.
Android P adds an implementation
of the GlobalPlatform Open
Mobile API to Android.
On supported
devices, apps can use
OMAPI to access NFC secure
elements on Android devices
to enable smart card payments
and other secure services.
The Neural Networks API was
introduced in Android 8.1
to provide support for
accelerated on-device machine
learning.
In Android P, we're expanding
and improving the API,
adding support for nine new Ops.
On Pixel 2, the DP1 build
includes an accelerated
driver for quantized models.
Android P is part of our
longer-term initiative
to modernize the foundations
of the platform and the apps
that run on it.
We announced recently
that Google Play
will require all app
updates to at least target
Android Oreo by November
2018 and require
apps with an NDK library to
provide 64-bit support in 2019.
In line with these
changes, Android P
will warn users
with a dialog when
they install an app that targets
an Android platform earlier
than Android 4.2,
and future versions
will continue to
increment that limit.
Every Android
developer should start
planning to migrate to
target at least API 26 now.
And we've built a
checklist of resources
to help and support this effort.
We're always looking for ways to
improve the user and developer
experience.
In this spirit, we're
working to ensure
that apps don't use
non-SDK interfaces,
since doing so risks crashes
for users and emergency rollouts
for developers.
In Android N, we restricted
the set of symbols
that NDK code could use.
And with Android P, we're
further increasing stability
by expanding these restrictions
to cover the SDK interfaces as
well.
In the preview,
you'll see a warning
when you use a non-SDK interface
that we plan to restrict.
If you feel that you'll
need the SDK API expanded
to stop using non-SDK
[? 1s, ?] please let
us know as soon as you
can via our bug tracker.
In Android P, we're
providing a standard system
dialog to prompt the user
to touch the fingerprint
sensor managing text and
placement as appropriate
for the device.
Apps can trigger the system
FingerprintDialog using
a new FingerprintDialog API.
We recommend switching to
the new system dialog as soon
as possible, as the
previous API may not
be compatible with new devices.
As part of a larger effort to
move all network traffic away
from clear text,
unencrypted HTTP to TLS,
we're also changing the
defaults for network security
configuration to block
all clear text traffic.
On Android P and higher,
apps with a network security
configuration must make
connections over TLS
unless they explicitly
opt into clear text
for specific domains.
To better ensure user
privacy, Android P
restricts all access to
microphones, cameras,
and sensors from idle apps.
When an app is idle, the
mic will report empty audio,
and the sensors will
stop reporting events,
while cameras used
by the app will
be disconnected
and generate errors
if the app tries to use them.
Android P gives the user control
over access to the Build.SERIAL
identifier by putting it
under the read phone state
permission.
Direct access to this
identifier has been
deprecated since Android 8.0.
Android P adds platform support
for edge-to-edge displays
with cutouts.
The status bar will adapt
its height automatically.
Apps with critical
immersive content
can use a new platform
API and window insets
to get the cutout
bounds and a new API
in the Window
Manager LayoutParams
to request layout
in the cutout area.
The updated MessagingStyle
notification
makes it easier to display
notifications involving
people or groups of people.
It provides a standardized way
to handle images and handle
suggested replies.
Give your users a seamless
transition to Android P.
Just download a device
or emulator system image,
install your app, and test.
The Android P Developer
Preview includes an updated SDK
with system images for testing
on the official Android
Emulator and on Pixel,
Pixel XL, Pixel 2, and Pixel
2 XL devices.
Speaking of the Emulator,
it's a great place
to test or develop
on Android P. It's
incredibly fast and
convenient to use,
and you can even model
long screens and screens
with a display cutout
for cameras and sensors.
After you've tested, handle
any P behavior changes,
make any necessary updates,
and publish to Google Play
without changing
the platform target.
Then, change your
app's targeting to P,
and run it with the full
Android P experience.
Explore the many new
features and APIs
you can take advantage
of in your app.
Take a look at the
API Diff Report
along with the Android
P API reference.
You can start building
with P by downloading
the Developer Preview SDK in
tools in the Android Studio.
We're also releasing an alpha
version of the 28.0.0 Support
Library for you to try.
Check out the release
notes for complete details.
We plan to update the
preview system images
and SDK regularly.
This initial release
is for developers
only and not intended for
daily or consumer use.
So we're making it available by
manual download in Flash only.
As we get closer
to a final product,
we invite consumers
to try it out as well,
and we'll open up enrollments
through Android Beta
at that time.
Stay tuned for details.
But for now, please note that
Android Beta is not currently
available for Android P.
As always, your
feedback is critical.
So please let us
know what you think.
The sooner we hear from you,
the more of your feedback
we can integrate.
Look in the video
description for details
on how to report issues.
And stay tuned.
This is just our first
preview, after all.
The Android P story
is just beginning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]